the has had enough of Nikki Haley so the
brutally attacks her now a lot of the
neocons are quietly coming along to that
position with the exceptions of Nikki
Haley and Joe Biden who still support
this what I believe is pointless war in
Ukraine and I think those with foreign
policy experience one thing that Joe
Biden and Nikki Haley have in common is
that neither of them could even state
for you three provinces in eastern
Ukraine that they want to send our
troops to actually fight for look at
that this is what want people to
understand these people have I mean she
has no idea what the hell the names of
those provinces are but she wants to
send our sons and daughters and our
troops and our military equipment to go
fight it this was brutal